[Music]
- medium Americanos come right up
what dude how are you so fast your first
kiss no I'm waiting oh I got it
Kevin you're good man
[Music]
this neighborhood is concerned about the
killing of a 17 year old do they have
any idea who did it whatever gang is in
and then they'll just hide him why is
everyone saying it's the game thing
police are still looking for leads in
the case of slain Kennedy High School
student Kevin Broadus you can see inside
our emotions are raw everybody in this
room is hurting kevin Broadus was not in
the game we appreciate your time will
you please send the next person in my
friend just got killed you can't expect
me just to sit around and not do
anything about it
the police have already made up their
minds they're gonna write this whole
thing off as a gang killing someone
needs to do something why are you so
interested it just doesn't really make
any sense why anyone will kill again I
don't know what maybe rich is gonna have
to learn to live with that
you stop this nonsense this is a murder
investigation you don't know what could
happen
he's mixed up with some heavy people
they're dangerous said you got something
for me
do you see where we are right now
my wife had to find this are you a
dealer no were you supplying my son
I'm worried about you if you came here
trying to talk me out of doing anything
crazy don't bother
can't be a part of this anymore now I
got nothing to lose
don't be stupid do not go
you